yes you notice the parrot was a
Norwegian blue yes no I've never seen
them do only in the sketch how did that
happen
why nobody noted I think the answer is
Graham Chapman who is sadly the only
Python who is not alive and he Graham
had a way of putting in these most
extraordinary inventive little moments
you couldn't see what will the way his
mind is working but well then just have
a parrot it was probably I think Graham
would decide it was a Norwegian blue
whichever wouldn't happen I mean so
they're probably a fee round now you
know sort of scale from in Python
television set we've been talking yeah
we've been talking about handball I
don't know if you know handball I don't
know actually that form of handball I
mean I know rugby and I know things like
that but this is very different and I'm
very it's different from rugby's yeah oh
yeah soccer and someone picked up the
ball and then the new sport was born but
yeah and also the Minister of Finance is
here I know how are you with mommy how I
am very conservative with a small C my
father was just terrible money
everything in the house was every single
even even one pound notes were washed
and used again you know and all the
coins for kept in in different pots you
know threatening bits their thicknesses
their shillings their so you ever want
to find any money you had to go round
the house of unscrewing things
so occasionally I ice or lash out but
I'm you know I've been married 46 years
I've lived in the same house for 48
years I'm not gonna sort of suddenly put
all my money in a bank
I mean the Pythons you must have done a
lot of money they were you tax planning
and very good with that
well pythons of good at comedy I think
very very bad at business we will want
some an American agent wanted to take
over the Python group it was a big
Hollywood producer and he took us to his
private house in somewhere off in New
York and explained to us this wonderful
way in which our earnings would go you
know off country various islands around
the world it was incredibly complicated
so they go to the Cayman Islands and
they go to Panama they don't grow
somewhere there it was like a Python
sketch but you said you know this way
you will save millions so we all nodded
and later in the day we're kind of
sitting around the pool
I said to John did you understand that
if I didn't understand he do you
understand it I understand it six of us
all Oxford graduate and no single person
understood what he is all about
since then we've kept our money in some
large storage you know probably not then
I don't think you should put your money
in strange Islands it has happened to
see some accidents there it did teach me
a lot about geography islands and
they're probably richer than anywhere
apart from possibly Norway I'm sorry and
freedom
except except that you're of course a
famous comedian and also now a famous
Globetrotter and the region and Swedish
viewers you are also a novelist and yes
you are you're out now with your second
novel called the truth yeah
it's there's such a thing as the truth
well I think the truth is if you want to
say there is a truth it's a very
detailed thing you know I am picking up
this pot this glass yes beyond that I
think various different people have
different ideas of what the truth is and
how they you know it's very difficult to
pin down exactly what the truth is so I
wanted to write a story about somebody
who believes there is a truth out there
he's a journalist hears he has fallen on
hard times he can't get work except for
writing for sort of commercial companies
and he out of the blue gets a chance to
write about the life of someone who he
considers to be absolutely the
personification of honesty decency the
truth and environmentalist to boot and
then well yeah exactly and the further
he goes into it the more complicated it
becomes and the more he realizes that
actually where the truth lies is very
very difficult and you know it the truth
is what anyone wants it to be so that's
the sort of I suppose the book is like
saying life is complicated it's talking
about traveling you're a you're a
Globetrotter
you've been almost in any corner of the
world do you see yourself as a traveler
or as an explorer oh well I'd like to
think of myself as an explorer when I
was growing up that's what I wanted to
do I wanted to be an explorer and yet
the world was being explored as every
year I grew up more of the world have
been explored there was nowhere else
really to go so I suppose I'm a traveler
but it's nice to feel that occasion you
might explore something but have you
ever been first somewhere
first somewhere God probably on the
probably on the sidewalks of Beverly
Hills I've the first person to walk
there because I mean seriously you go to
Los Angeles I never see anybody they
just cut their garage doors open
smoothly the car come smoothly out and
off they go there's no one on the street
at all so I think probably I used to I
used to like walking the streets of Los
Angeles a flag you walk around them and
the police stop you wait where you going
so I think probably that's it
also I've been on the north pole which
you you I mean the north pole is the
Surratt Shore geographical position but
actually because it's on moving ice all
the time the pole I stood on is probably
not the pole that you might have been
first the others stood on at that
particular time you have slip one like I
think I remember you slept in the tent
on the South Pole yes yes they have a
house there did they have some housing
there don't they yes the South Pole is
there's an American base there and the
Americans sort of have a base which is
is really they they look after on behalf
of all the nations and it's dug down
underneath the ice so right close to the
South Pole only a few yards from where
Amundsen and Scott would have got to
there is now an underground living area
where you see guys in shorts you know
going along eating blueberry pie and
listening to music and all that playing
snooker but if you go to the South Pole
you are not allowed to stay there unless
you're a qualified scientist and I've
got you know the right papers saying you
must give some help to this magazine
scientists well clears you in well
they'll let you in but you can't sleep
there they'll let you in and give you a
cup of tea and then kick you out again
minus 50 degrees so we had to yeah we
had to sleep at the South Pole in our
own tent and there were about six or
seven of us and I decided you know in
case I wanted to have a pee in the night
I would sleep at the front of the tent
by the entrance to the tent and that's
where I put my sleeping bag
unfortunately we have with us an elderly
American who wanted to go to all the
continents of the world and he was he
was incontinent and he come past him
with his boot and then he go outside and
relieve himself and then come back and
continent black and blue by the morning
and this is the fun of it all you know
not many people do things like that
quite rightly so I kind of what kind of
track I mean when you travel
commercially with your with your wife
for example what kind of traveler are
you are you the type that would be like
three hours before on the airport or are
you the impulsive traveler than okay I
become more and more cautious about
catching planes I get to the airport
before it's built
I do like I do like to get there and of
course airports now you can live in
their porch I some I think some people
do all these people in restaurants and
shops by ties buying you know suits
going to the salmon bar going to the
champagne bar they going anywhere they
must just live there I'm sure so there's
lots to do and I'd far rather be there
way in advance than be stuck in traffic
on the way and having to weave your way
through the cars and all that what about
the pythons I mean should you you must
have traveled a lot with the point ins
yes we did I mean the days
yeah I mean we mainly Python traveling
was either up to Scotland to film we did
the Holy Grail up in Scotland or else it
was to go on promotional trips when you
just saw the airport
you saw studio and you saw a hotel and
that was it but we did we did travel to
Tunisia to film The Life of Brian that
was what that was great what kind of
travel companions are they oh you know
very fussy very finicky you know and I
you sharing a caravan with John Cleese
you know he had peanut shells all over
the floor things like that you know just
a Graham Chapman bless him used to
always you know as soon as we got on the
plane he'd asked for a gin and tonic
so those journeys were endless across
the Atlantic but that there you know but
they're always sort of they're good fun
I mean they're good a lot of guys to be
with if you've got a sense of humor but
the airport staff don't have a sense of
humor we are now about to hear some
actually some folk music yeah this is
this is American folk music it's very
accessible and very nice it's a band
called the Lumineers
I must have heard a lot of folk music
yeah I have do you enjoy it
actually I do the more obscure and
strange it is the more I enjoy in a nose
flutes and odd things like that
brilliant what people what orifices
people will use to play an instrument
through well let's see
thank you so much for coming all of you
your novel the truth is out
just to mention that then tell there's
only four kracken high also for kid ninh
international
you